game spots 2019 game of the year is
getting a brand new boss rush mode
a hulk sized beta is on the way for the
avengers and killjoy
is valerian's newest agent i'm persia
and you've reached your save state for
wednesday july 29th
get prepared to take on your favorite
bosses over and over
in sakura shadows die twice which was
gamespot's 2019 game of the year
this mode and a bunch of other stuff is
coming in a free update this october
reflection of strength will streamline
the boss fighting process
without replaying the whole game as
passpose can be fought again by visiting
sculptors idols there is also the
gauntlet of strength that is a boss rush
challenge that leaves you with just one
life
in your skill but there's more wolfe
will be getting three new forms that
will change his outward appearance and
remnants
will allow you to send 30 second
recordings of your actions to the worlds
of other shinobi
so if you're having trouble with some of
the new modes then maybe you can watch
some clips from fellow shinobi and try
to get some new strategies
today's avengers war table live stream
showed off a truly hulk sized beta
and it's going to be here in just a few
weeks but of course this beta is said to
be just a taste
of what the full game is going to be
like on release we saw gameplay from
four playable characters
kamala khan black widow the hulk and
iron man
we also got to see a good look at iron
man's hulkbuster ultimate and you'll be
able to play the beta solo or with
friends in harm challenge rooms
and war zone or drop zone missions harm
challenge rooms have increasingly
difficult waves of enemies
war zones are repeatable missions that
can last from 10 minutes to 2
hours and drop zones are more quick
encounters
hawkeye is back by popular demand and
will be the game's first post-launch
character added for free
he will have his own story missions and
will also be added alongside
a new villain the beta will be dropping
between august 7th and august 14th but
it's all dependent on if
and where you decide to pre-order the
game so if you need
all the details on that to make sure you
get to play as soon as possible
then make sure you visit gamespot.com
move over cypher because i might have a
new mane
after some initial leaks valorent has
officially announced a new agent
killjoy is joining the roster with act 2
on august
4th which is less than a week away being
a riot game
it's really hard not to draw parallels
between characters like heimerdinger
with her robot turret and teemo with the
stealth mine
but killjoy looks like she also has some
remnants of
rays with her alarm bot that hunts down
and explodes on enemies within range
lockdown is her ultimate ability and is
a giant dome that will detain any
enemies caught in the radius
from the brief showcase we've seen so
far her kit looks super fun
but also looks like it's going to shake
up the meta
quite a bit so she's gonna be arriving
with act
two which is in less than a week but it
also signifies the end of act one
so if you didn't finish your battle pass
yet you have less than a week to do it
get on it we are a handful of days away
from august which means that we have one
more month left of our play for all
donation drive
there's still time to donate to support
black lives matter and covet 19 relief
efforts but you can also contribute by
going to store.gamespot.com
and purchasing some awesome merch that
will have all the proceeds sent to the
same
great causes that's all for today i'm
persia and you can follow me on twitter
at persia underscore xo
and make sure that you reach your save
state tomorrow
see you later
you